( Amy )
This haircut is a disaster.
You'll be hearing from
my lawyer, okay.
I'm gonna shut this
entire operation down.
Oh, God.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't see you.
No, it's fine,
I'm sorry.
Let me help you.
This-- this
is mine.
Oh, right,
I'm sorry.
Uh, this is weird.
I never do this
but...
I love your hair.
Oh, really, no.
I think it's
the most amazing hairdo
I've ever seen
in my life.
What would you even
call a shape like that?
Oh, I...
a circle?
Okay, yeah,
yeah, I see that now.
A hair circle.
Huh, well...
I guess I love hair
circles, who knew?
Life is so full of
lessons and surprises.
Do you wanna grab
coffee or something?
Uh, yes,
yes, I would.
Okay.
Great.
I'm Amy.
Oh, it's nice
to meet you.
I can't believe you
like my perm.
I was really
mad about it.
♪♪
Oh, wow, cool dog.
Is that
a permanent dog?
What?
Come here.
I love you.
Hi, you're the most
beautiful thing
I've ever
seen in my life.
Yes, you are.
I love your
hair circle.
Does he go to
a salon to get this done?
Look at the golden
light on you.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I love you.
♪♪
And he's like really,
really hot.
So what's the catch?
I think he may only
be interested in me
because
I have this perm.
You're being crazy.
I don't know.
So then I said,
"You, sir,
may sit on my face."
( all laughing )
And then what did
your perm say, Angie?
What?
I mean, what did
your dad say, perm-perm?
♪♪
Yeah, no...
He's only interested in
you because of your perm.
Also, I think he thinks
your name is Angie.
He definitely thinks
my name is Angie.
What should I do?
He's really hot.
I know.
♪♪
Angie...
my life has changed since
the day I ran into you...
and your perm.
And I think it's time
that you and I became...
... permanent.
Oh, my God!
Huh?
Oh, baby.
Oh, my God!
What the hell?!
What's wrong?
What happened?!
What, my hair?
Yes!
It grows out, what's
wrong with you?
It's called
a permanent.
They just call
it that.
It's so fucked up!
Wait, what?!
God, it's so
fucking ugly!
No!
( screaming )
What's wrong
with you?
( screaming )
Oh, no!
My head.
I'm so sorry,
come here.
No.
Give me the ring.
No!
Cliff, are you
coming back?
Perm!
♪